hey guys it is Friday which means I'm
here to let you know that all the
important things that happened in gaming
this week a new Dark Souls 3 update
landed this week on all platforms which
has made a number of adjustment and
fixes the patch adjusted the performance
of the great sword the dances enchanted
sword and the winged night twin axes
among other items although specifically
how these weapons have been altered was
not divulged the update also contained a
number of bug fixes although bandai
namco did not specify whether they would
address the crashing issues p city
players have been facing since launch
this week sega announced an emulator for
the sega megadrive which will be able to
access through steam the sega megadrive
classic tub will launch on april 28 and
access to the hub will be free for
players who own any of the sega
megadrive classic titles available on
steam they get added that despite the
region specific name the update is also
landing in America where the console was
called the stagger Genesis the hub will
feature local co-op for supported games
optional graphic enhancements filters
the ability to save at any time as well
as controller and keyboard support all
the games will also have Steam Workshop
support so modding will be possible you
can check out the full list of titles in
our story on game swipe a gamestop
employee sent images of an unannounced
batman HD collection to Eurogamer which
backed up a report from march of last
year reportedly batman arkham asylum
batman arkham city and the dlc will
arrive on playstation 4 and xbox one as
part of the collection batman arkham
origins won't be included as it was
developed outside of Rocksteady by WB
games montreal it's rumored that the HD
collection will have updated visuals
that have been optimized for ps4 and
Xbox one you're a gamer reports that it
will hit shelves on jun 10 turns out you
guys love board games as much as you
love dark souls because the dark souls
board game was funded on kickstarter in
just three minutes
dark souls the board game is a tabletop
game designed for wonderful players
being made by Sting forged games in
partnership with bandai namco you'll
choose a class a flight monsters find
treasure take on bosses and do it all
with awesome miniatures the campaign is
calling for 50,000 pounds and at the
time of writing it had collected over 1
million pounds in funding and its first
48 hours with 24 days of funding left to
go which is bloody ridiculous all that
extra funding means loads of stretch
goals have been achieved so the game is
looking better and better if you want
the board game you can guarantee
yourself a copy by backing the campaign
at the 75-pound level there's been a lot
of talk about the reported high-powered
ps4 codenamed Nero and here's the
highlight both giant bomb and Eurogamer
obtained documentation that detailed the
new console and how Sonia handling its
arrival it's been reported that the near
version of the ps4 will have a more
powerful CPU GPU and memory bandwidth
allegedly every ps4 game will be
required to ship with a base ps4 mode
and a near mode which will support 4k
output improved frame rate and other
graphical enhancements Giant Bomb
claimed the system will sell for four
hundred bucks whenever it's released
Eurogamer added the dev kits are being
sent out already but not everybody is
thrilled at the idea bio a co-founder
Greg Zeschuk has said that it would be a
pain in the ass for devs and consumers
while many of you have expressed
frustration given you'd recently picked
yourself up a ps4 let me know down in
that comment section how you feel about
this week stories and if you're
interested in the dark souls would get
this week on site we take a look at the
story of the overwatch check out seven
times Game of Thrones characters
seriously messed up and we take a look
at the Mirror's Edge catalyst paper that
is everything I got for you this week
but be sure to have yourselves a great
weekend and Mary will be back with you
next week to let you know all the gaming
news
you